[Música]
economía intelecto américa de france 24
y ya estaba conmigo en el estudio daniel
hablando nuevamente danny vamos a hablar
del primer proyecto del nuevo gobierno
de colombia que es económicamente
hablando por supuesto de una reforma
tributaria que tiene pues en expectativa
a todo el país así es de raúl una muy
esperada reforma proyecto de reforma
tributaria que se espera en el
transcurso de la mañana sea presentada
por el ministro de hacienda josé antonio
ocampo es un día después de la posesión
con esta iniciativa se busca entonces
reducir la brecha entre ricos y pobres
que es una de las más altas de la región
como lo recordaba el presidente gustavo
petro
el 10 por ciento de la población
colombiana
tiene el 70 por ciento de la riqueza por
eso proponemos una economía basada en la
producción
el trabajo y el conocimiento y es por
ello por lo que proponemos una reforma
tributaria que genere
justicia beni la que se sabe esta
propuesta los detalles que tenemos hasta
el momento bueno se sabe muy poco porque
han sido más que todo declaraciones ante
los medios la educación por parte de las
autoridades económicas pero lo que sí se
sabe es que no va a tener mensajes de
urgencia en el congreso porque la idea
es tener el tiempo suficiente para
discutir la la reforma esperaría un
recaudo inicial de 5 mil 800 millones de
dólares su eje principal es el aumento
de tributación a quienes tienen más
dinero y el combate de la evasión fiscal
la reforma ha sido discutida ampliamente
una de las conclusiones en medios
locales es que quien devenga
mensualmente lo equivalente a 10
millones de pesos que son unos dos mil
quinientos dólares o diez salarios
mínimos mensuales no verán incrementos
en sus impuestos el presidente de petro
también hizo varias propuestas
económicas una de ellas fue el fondo
monetario internacional le dijo que
quiere cambiar parte de la deuda externa
por acciones contra él
bueno dan y vamos a hablar ahora de otro
tema el paquete de la inflación y el
cambio climático de eeuu que está a
punto de ser ley a sí señor le faltan la
cámara baja y la firma del presidente
para que se convierta en ley la
vicepresidenta kamala harris emitió el
voto de desempate en el senado este es
un proyecto de 430 mil millones de
dólares que estarán destinados a reducir
las emisiones de carbono y cambiar a los
consumidores a energías verdes al tiempo
que reduce los costos de los
medicamentos recetados para personas de
la tercera edad también refuerza la
aplicación de impuestos a las
corporaciones
nuestro proyecto de ley reduce la
inflación reduce los costos crea
millones de empleos en la industria
manufacturera y mejora nuestra seguridad
energética es el paquete climático más
audaz en la historia de eeuu el senado
aprobó el proyecto de ley más importante
para combatir la crisis climática
los sonidos nuestra solo en esta batalla
hay otros países que están tomando
medidas contra la inflación y le voy a
dar algunos ejemplos en américa latina
brasil está presionando a petrobras para
que baje los precios de la gasolina en
europa alemania planea introducir un
impuesto al consumo de gas natural desde
el primero de octubre francia aprueba un
paquete de alivio de 20 mil millones de
euros italia hizo lo propio con 17 mil
millones de euros en asia india
restringió las exportaciones de
alimentos y japón desplegó un paquete de
ayudas que incluyó pagos en efectivo a
las familias con niños y el medio
oriente de turquía aumentó el salario
mínimo en un 30% y un tema que nos gusta
la historia la novela de león más que la
empresa la red social 'twitter' pues
esta novela hasta el viernes y vamos en
que y la mosca había contrademandado a
twitter porque dice que si no cumple con
su compromiso de comprarla es porque el
precio acordado de 44 mil millones de
dólares no se compadece con la
información real que le están otorgando
sobre cuentas falsas el fin de semana
volvió a abrir una puerta que podría
sellar el trato pero solamente si la
empresa proporciona un método de
muestreo que le garantice que estas
cifras son confiables tweeter calcula
que menos del 5 por ciento de sus
cuentas activas corresponde a spam o
falsas el magnate de autos de lujo hizo
una encuesta en twitter más del 65%
creen que no es verdad indicador son las
bolsas asiáticas cerraron mixtas y wall
street abrió al alza con los ojos
puestos esta semana sobre el dato de
inflación en eeuu que va a ser publicado
este miércoles europa opera con
ganancias a pocas horas del cierre se
recuperan así de un mal viernes después
de que los buenos datos de empleo en
eeuu se hicieran prever una nueva subida
de tazas hoy realidad 18 por ciento
crecieron las exportaciones chinas en
julio de este año a iván así la
esperanza de que no haber recesión en el
mundo danny como siempre muchísimas
gracias por toda la información
económica y vamos a pasar a hablar de
salud con marina sardina